more than 100 million people are saddled
with health care debt in the u.s that
includes about 40 percent of all adults
according to an investigation by kaiser
health news and npr a new poll finds one
quarter of american adults with health
care debt owe more than five thousand
dollars in partnership with kaiser
health news our consumer investigative
correspondent anna warner spoke with one
family on the front lines of this debt
crisis anna good morning good morning
nate what we're talking about here is a
health care system that forces massive
numbers of people into debt debt that
ripples through their lives for years
and has major consequences as one
chicago family found
marcus and ali ward planned carefully
before having children he runs a
non-profit she's a neonatal nurse
practitioner and they put their finances
in order before getting pregnant i think
we thought we knew everything that could
be that could come down the pipe so it's
like you are unprepared no matter how
prepared you are what they couldn't
prepare for were twin boys born
prematurely at just 30 weeks both
diagnosed with cerebral palsy and other
issues milo would spend eight weeks in
the neonatal intensive care unit theo
four months the costs quickly exhausted
their insurance suddenly they found
themselves owing 80 000
what went through your mind it was a lot
of panic and it was a lot of like do we
file for bankruptcy do we like
they can't repossess a child so i guess
i get to keep them
right right what do i do now allie ward
says the stress blocked some of the joy
surrounding the twins birth instead of
being able to be present in the
experience of being a new mom and a new
family a lot of times it was oh my gosh
like how are we going to make this work
the couple used all their savings maxed
out their credit cards and wiped out
their retirement accounts and still it
wasn't enough you still wound up with
debt that you're still paying on yeah
does that make you mad
yes
i think we are even matter about the
fact that like what about people who
don't have all the benefits that we had
in the situation many are struggling a
new poll from the kaiser family
foundation finds in the past five years
more than half of u.s adults have gone
into debt because of medical or dental
bills one in seven people with debt say
they've been denied access to a hospital
doctor or other provider because of
unpaid bills and about two-thirds have
put off care they or a family member
need because of cost care just costs so
much more in the united states than
almost anywhere else in the world dr
erin carroll is a health policy
researcher what do you think is driving
this medical debt crisis i think it's a
combination of the high price of health
care in america coupled with the fact
that even with insurance
americans still out of pocket have to
pay a significant amount for health care
that worry never goes away you know
you're just waiting for the other shoe
to drop which is what happened to the
wards again in 2019 the couple had
enrolled their then seven-year-old twins
in physical occupational and speech
therapy programs doctors said they
needed to help with their cerebral palsy
but then they say their insurance
company which had been paying for the
sessions suddenly reversed course
sending them dozens of denial letters
for past therapy sessions the mail
person they actually knocked on the door
and they're like um these won't fit
through your slot so here you go and
they handed us
a bundle of
these letters the denial letters yep
were for how much roughly about forty
thousand dollars
forty thousand dollars so here you go
again
right this time the wards wound up suing
their insurance company and they won
cutting the new debt to just a few
thousand dollars but they're still
paying on the original debt from the
twins birth roughly 500 each month so
how are you doing now financially we're
recovering
but we're still in a
pretty
drawn out recovery from it on the bright
side allie ward says they're a family it
seems like the part that really worked
out for us is that
you know our love for each other and our
love for our kids
well the wards say they're glad their
twins are thriving thanks in part to
those expensive therapies over the years
but they're worried about potential
surprise bills in the future how much
medical debt americans actually have in
total is hard to know because so much
isn't recorded and much of it is put on
credit cards you won't be surprised to
hear that a 2019 kaiser analysis
estimated that collective medical debt
totaled at least
billion dollars that's larger than the
economy of greece
we are failing each other in this
country i know we are
you know i would say you're going to
need to talk to a therapist with these
debts so large but the cost coverage is
even worse than the medical health
coverage yeah and uncovered right and
people feel a lot of emotions too
connected with it guilt and shame and
why can't they handle this themselves
and the truth is you cannot prepare for
an unexpected medical expense
a million dollars nor can you choose
right you could arguably not go to
college put off the car not buy the
house arguably right
you get sick it's not a choice right it
just happens right you need health care
well soon we got to be able to do better
yeah alrighty anna thank you